listen i was about to go to the airport
within the next two 30 minutes okay
because putting all this behind us you
know for the next couple days we're
gonna take some days off go do some
podcast guest appearances in different
spots and then someone sends me a story
a fresh prince ceo going to buy
firearms for the first time look at this
all right guys i'm here with my boy
peter helping me with my first guns
shout out to you man hey pleasure
pleasure walter thank you hello everyone
out there yeah we here at american
security consultants we're experts in
firearms training situational awareness
defensive tactics
are you serious
and you think you're an alpha male you
think you're fit to lead other men
there's two scenarios here maybe fresh
always really wanted a gun and this just
happened to spring up and it was just
appointment he set beforehand and
whatever
but to post that on ig after if i'm
giving you the benefit of doubt okay
maybe you're that [ __ ] stupid
to post that on ig after you challenge a
man to a fight insult his wife insult
the haitian community and the haitians
there right you're in miami you're an
idiot
you then go and post stories after you
start backing out and getting scared you
post stories about you buying firearms
because he says oh we're going to go to
the boxing match we're going to do this
legally
and you post that on ig
let's say this is a scenario that really
happened okay
that means you lack so much
self-awareness to realize how it's going
to look optically
that you have no idea about anything
relating to social cues you don't
understand how to communicate to people
how you're perceived that's basic 101
stuff that's crazy
so i don't know how you're fit to teach
other men
how to adjust and how to learn game on
the fly you don't even see how awkward
and stupid you look
or option two which i think is what
everyone else believes just like me
this man wrote a check
that his ass can't check
and now after he insults all this and
does all this talking he went out and
bought firearms
and this is your king
this is the guy that you guys look up to
to learn how to speak to women this man
can't speak to people he doesn't
understand how to communicate how can
you have gain
if you don't understand social cues he's
a fraud
and young men listen in the military you
can have the highest rank you want okay
we don't respect an officer just because
they got the rank we'll do our job
but we don't believe in him
respect
leadership it's earned through leading
by example
this
is your man you know why i said the
emperor has no clothes because it's a
story about two jesters who walk into a
city naked all right and they concoct
this plan to fool the whole city that
they are emperors
so they get one guy and they get a
couple other hobos to carry uh uh some
sort of dice and they carry them through
town and everyone starts making way
because it's like oh my god there's
these guys on a dice look at them the
emperor's in town we don't know from
what country but they looked apart
and then someone points out wait
the emperor has no clothes you want to
know why because an emperor would never
walk around with no clothes the same way
a real
man
would never go out and tell someone a
boxing match insult his integrity in
this honor and then say yeah let's box
and then when the man accepts you go and
buy guns and you dodge talking about
money y'all are crazy
and this is not even to encourage
violence i don't want none of that okay
i'm not about to start talking about
that's crazy talk this to let young men
know on this platform because just
because they're older than you and they
show a big game doesn't mean they're
about that life
too many frauds out here
too many frauds out here right i call it
the blind leading the blind
careful who you take advice from
i made that mistake in the past so
here's my advice to you drop all these
[ __ ] goobers and just go look up some
patrice o'neill you'll thank me later
oh my god priest can't even be here
because we don't have enough time
unfortunately but best believe the
reason why preachers not talking so much
lately
is because he has nothing to say he has
things he wants to do
so consider me speaking on his behalf at
least for today
[Music]
a
be